autour de la place d'armes le temps à
effacer les blessures et la maison gros
bornes diffuse toujours son charme un
peu austère
qui se souvient qu'il ya 150 ans
elle était souffre du canon
[Musique]
contre toute attente en ce mois de
novembre 1870 les 17000 soldats de
belfort résiste et se battre
farouchement
beaucoup viennent pourtant d'être
mobilisés certains par exemple on le
sait n'ont jamais tiré avant d'avoir
rencontré un plus siens ils savent pas
épauler ils savent pas visé donc ce qui
complexifie bien entendu lorsqu'on mène
des actions en direction des débuts des
prussiens de l'assaillant qui lui fait
partie on va dire à une armée quand même
un peu mieux entraînées mieux préparer
mieux équipés la population elle se
protège comme l eau des canons prussiens
l'avantagent dit on sait que l'on voit
souvent arrivé des obus c'est le maire
de belfort de l'époque qui le qui en
porte le témoignage on pouvait vivre
dans les maisons de la ville de belfort
jusqu'au premier étage jusqu'à sept
étages là le les obus n'était pas encore
suffisamment puissant on n'est pas
encore dans la première guerre mondiale
pour que à nos bus puisse vraiment
atteindre l'intérieur d'une maison
ceux qui ont une cave vont aller trouver
refuge à l'intérieur ce qui va être très
très important dans la propagation des
maladies qui vous frappe et de toute la
population de belfort et la guérison
une chose est sûre il n'y a pas de
pénurie d'alcool au milieu de ce chaos
des cantiniers prussiens vendre ou même
du schnaps aux français
quand on parle de sièges on s'attend à
ce qu'ils aient aucune possibilité
d'entrée et de sortie d'une
fortification ou d'une ville fortifiée
com helfaut
mais dans la réalité eh bien on peut
rentrer et sortir assez facilement parce
que l'assaillant n'est pas partout et
n'est surtout pas partout en même temps
le soldat du siège de belfort ne souffre
pas de la fin il est suffisamment
pourvue en ouverture un tel point qui va
même se permettre de donner une partie
de cette nourriture lui même à la
population civile on va appeler salle
pas des pauvres la guerre de siège et
éprouvante mais des habitants sont aux
côtés des soldats pour les soutenir ou
les soigner c'est le cas d'une jeune
femme de la ville elle s'appelle marie
lefebvre c'est une mère courage
belfortaine finalement qui s'est dévoué
en tant que volontaire alors c'est
important de dire ça puisqu'on est dans
une période de notre histoire où les
blessés ne sont pas comment seulement
être considérée par l'autorité
administrative et militaire
on commence véritablement à organiser
des services ambulances aux abords des
villes assiégées sur les champs de
bataille donc c'est une relation humaine
qui se met en oeuvre qui débouchera
notamment après la guerre de 1870 sur la
création du souvenir français
il existe un portrait de marie lefebvre
hasard de l'histoire
il se trouve aujourd'hui dans la salle
d'honneur de la délégation militaire du
territoire de belfort
ce tableau il restera longtemps ici je
pense que tant que la caserne existera
et que l'amérique belfort nous fera
l'honneur de le conserver on le lait
trait ici et c'est tout à leur honneur
pour nous de savoir ce portrait de
madame lefebvre ou chez nous elle devait
être courageuse marie lefebvre assiégée
bombardée depuis des semaines
belfort désespère mais heureusement une
armée est en route pour venir la libérer
[Musique]